the problem of the cost of college is an
enormous one and it's real and frankly
it's true whether you're a liberal arts
grad you're an engineering graduate
because you're still facing those those
those issues of debt and is it worth it
so I have a few things to say about that
first is the data still shows that a
college education is worth the
investment that is your earnings will be
higher over your lifetime because you
have a college degree and they will be
significantly higher than the cost of
that college degree over the lifetime
point 12 there isn't that much
difference in the lifetime earnings of
an engineer and graduate and a non
engineering graduate the engineering
graduates start out higher but it
equalizes after a while point 3 the real
change that one has to hope is is
happening is that the cost of college is
going down and that it will therefore
allow people to be more experimental to
follow their passions to you know to
pursue what they want to and the cost of
college is going down because
information technology and the
information revolution are finally
hitting colleges finally hitting
education education is a feel remarkably
unchanged basically in you know several
thousand years and if you think about
the way the ancient Greeks thought its
schools guy would stand up in front of a
classroom teach a bunch of people and
they would listen and that's really what
a college seminar is even today right
but now it's changing because online
education is going to massively change
the way in which education is delivered
but also the way it is priced and if
that happens my hope is that it will
produce a huge expansion of liberal
education for everybody but it will also
allow people to be more risk seeking in
terms of their educational choices if
you're paying you know a thousand
dollars for 20 online courses then it's
not as difficult to say I'm just going
to follow my passion get really good at
this perfect it do really well and
whether it's English or history or
philosophy or physics or chemistry you
will do it in a way that that really
reflects who you are in your
intellectual career
curiosity and you're probably going to
be better at it if you do something your
passion with that if universities cannot
get their cost structures under control
we have a problem no matter what and
problem is frankly beyond the issue of
liberal education or its stem more
engineering it is just that it is
getting to the point where it is it is
unaffordable we have a problem with two
areas of our economy we have rung
inflation out of every other aspect of
the economy in the last 40 years the two
areas where costs have risen several
times the rate of inflation for 40 years
now our health care and education and
they share some similar characteristics
in both cases the consumer tends to be
somewhat price insensitive because they
view this as something that you can't
put a monetary value on the customer is
not the person actually paying often
there's a federal government or
governmental involvement with lots of
third-party payments so the price
signals are complicated and muted the
consumer is not as price sensitive and
that allows for enormous amounts of cost
distortion and frankly inflation so I
think that in both areas you're going to
see information technology begin to
change that dynamic and if it doesn't
happen look you can't have in education
rise at three times the rate of
inflation for another 30 years that is
simply unsustainable
you